if you are surprised by the re-election
of Heart of Ronald McDaniel 111 votes to
Harmony it's 53 and then Mike Lindell
got four votes if you're surprised by
that you haven't been paying terribly
close attention to the Republican Party
the the way that the party committees
work the way that elections work broadly
does not correspond
often if ever at all to what people in
certain political bubbles are talking
about on Twitter that's not how it works
some people are very very upset about
this they say no we can't that's
terrible Rana didn't do a good job now
she's still running things this is
terrible I don't really care who runs
the RNC I like Rana I like our meat I
like Mike Lindell for that matter I
don't really care all that much it's not
a great job to have it involves a lot of
really granular kinds of decisions and
and most importantly of all any
significant Improvement to to the
Republican party or to U.S politics is
going to come from outside of the Party
Committee